[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what is up everybody how's it going
happy friday oh snap it's friday thank
goodness because that means we're
playing some animal crossing today
with the one and only felicia day how
are you thanks for joining us
hello i'm pretty good how are you i
am great excited to visit your island oh
god i'm sorry
i have tokyo drift i'm not kidding i
have
um i have one of my left my left
controller is drifty
so if i just start running to the left
for no reason that's
exactly why so sorry about that it's all
good the dreaded drift well yeah
thanks for having me i'm excited i'm
already loving the diy area
and the donkeys
yeah i'll let you uh you can follow me
around i think that we're gonna go to
your island second because i think
you're probably bet
you know you're just gonna wipe the
floor with me but i do like
what i've done with the island i've been
played obsessively i didn't count the
hours but i don't want to
um so let's see i think we'll start
let's start going to the right like we
have my duckies here
and i really like that and then i'm
really proud of the flower arrangement
here and this oh you know this little
area took a long time to nail but
um i really like the way that i put the
flowers here and
honestly my entrance looks a lot like
this so really
i'm good i'm i'm amongst yeah okay good
ruling it's great um i'm gonna give you
a tour of two houses
because basically i play this game with
my three-year-old daughter
and she has i'm gonna show you my tiki
bar first um
this is an area i'm still working on the
landscaping of it i keep putting more
plants in
and then i don't have enough plants and
then i take them out
so i'm kind of trying to balance out
um exactly how that's working but i do
i do enjoy a lot of the aspects of yeah
exactly
you can really sit down have a have a
blended like a pina colada
i know man this is really making me miss
going to the beach i know right
exactly thank you so much we like little
children your chin heights
behind that chest um i really like this
sort of like beach side vibe you can't
get on those stools but it's fine half
this game you can't do anything with it
so i really like this uh use of the
beach although i like i said i'm working
on the landscaping i'm kind of liking
the whole
red lily vibe because it feels kind of
tropical so oh yeah
yeah i love it good i like your deck too
oh thank you i love that um that yeah i
use that a lot i use the default wood
too and i have one other i really
i need 400 more custom slots that's the
problem
but you know they won't give it to us
and it's ridiculous um
so we actually have uh some questions in
the chat anita was wondering
how you came up with your island designs
like what's your inspiration
so i there's various things like i
really like
the idea of doing like um restaurants
because i'm a super foodie so you'll see
there's a lot of areas to eat
and um i kind of just went with the
natural terrain i had some ideas and
especially when i like pick up some um
various
pieces of thing you know like if i pick
up a tiki
you know i got tiki torch i like i'll do
a tiki bar so it
is dependent on like what's in nook um
on the day that inspires me
so this is my daughter's oh my goodness
so this is what she loves pink and black
and white and my mods
on my discord discord dot gg slash
felicia day
amazing animal crossing area and they
brought over a lot of these flowers
because i am frankly too
um she loves saber-toothed pink flowers
that you can take from my island to give
to her
yay yay so this is her house we're
working on getting a lot of
butterflies even though i had other
ideas for these butterflies she one of
them in her yard so
this is her house and she did when you
decorated this
with i mean i'm not kidding she picked
all of this
so you want to see i'm obsessed with
pink also
oh okay good so you're gonna feel at
home in this house except this is a
three-year-old
mind you okay so everything i put down
is a three-year-old picking it out
oh my goodness this is her crate
this is her creepy room um
so basically she's like more skulls and
more candles and that is what i do
at night this is super creepy because
the wallpaper glows and the candles are
super bright
nice yeah it's definitely got an eye for
style everything i'm sure the happy home
academy oh wait she got a goal she got a
gold she did she got a goal she had 86
000 points
um we're working on the kitchen right
now i think we need like an island or
something but she picked out
i i go through a lot of floors and walls
and this is what she picked for her
kitchen
amazing a lot of a lot of animals in
here too
oh thank you for the applause that's
very sweet i'm like and my character
with pink hair i'm like she should just
live here
you should live here yeah you know and
then um we yeah you should
well keep going um this is her bedroom
and it was her request that the minute
you walk in you could see toilet
things she really wanted a pink toilet
which one of my mods sent me
awesome and a bidet and she picked out
this uh
dungeon wall so this is a sort of
eclectic room
she really likes that i love the hunk i
know she
the honk really makes that bed you'll
notice there's ants in every bedroom she
really likes those ants cute
and and mind you like this all started
with us playing together and i
gave her one room in my house and she
decided she wanted the upstairs and
downstairs of my house
and then when i got her her own house
she decided she did not want to move out
of my house
so she has a whole full house
and two rooms in my house the biggest
one oh no i went to the wrong room
no you did i accidentally left no no
yeah i accidentally left my tokyo drift
took me out
oh no whoops come back i'll come back
and come back
oh my goodness so this is a cute room i
really like this because she liked the
um
the walls and then she was like put a
car there and then so i found all the
cars
nice so i kind of like that that's kind
of nice
yeah it kind of looks like they're
driving down the road exactly
right and there's a really super bad
storm and people
might be crashing at each other i
probably should have people going too
late so then we'll go upstairs
i just i want to show off her room
because i'm really proud of her
for really curating this this is her
um aquarium
she wanted all of these in here i'm like
you know we could take this big one out
and like no
she likes the big one the arowana
big one right friend center yeah that is
awesome yeah when you have this
room yeah when you need this why do you
need to even go to the museum you know
what i'm saying
watch out blathers got something yeah
blather's got some competition here
i love that and the floor is all perfect
yep
yeah no she picked it all out and then
downstairs is the last room
we just redid this room it was a little
it had like shot well i had pink
chocolate balls and then she i got the
don't go anywhere tokyo drift um and
then she decided to change the fame here
cute wow i have not seen this wall and
it's amazing it's really beautiful right
yeah i got the wall and then she said i
need some grass so i made her the grass
and then i got this uh t-rex and that
was really what changed this whole
thing so i need more stuff on the walls
always and she took my butterfly
which i was really proud of and wanted
to put someone else on the island but
well you at least you know butterflies
in a good home exactly
it's looking nice so anyway yeah that's
calliope's room and so basically i moved
her in
and she won't move out of my house and
also i had three other houses on this
lot
so she kept saying i need more mama i
need more
so i had to move two other houses to
give her this insane
insanely large yard if that's not love i
don't know what it is
okay yeah it's true um
then we'll go this way you know i think
i'll go yeah we'll do that and then
we'll go up
clearly i have some you know there's
always these spaces where you just i
don't know what kind of flowers to put
here
um this is my house i guess we could
tour my house
yeah okay purple themes here
purple thing yeah i love my favorite
flower in the whole game is the orange
hyacinth
so that's basically what i was kind of
basing it on
oh nice so i went for a sort of a
restoration hardware vibe here
and i keep thinking oh i've had this
design for a long time and i keep
thinking you should change it i'm like
no i love it i would live in this room
exactly right and so
i have sort of a western theme going on
in my kitchen which i
again i i need to do a little
development in my kitchen
but i do like um i wish there were
windows
with this wallpaper but i do love the
wallpaper
yeah i guess the idea is that you're
outside so
but still i feel the same way because in
my kitchen i have a wallpaper that has
no windows and i'm like man this would
be yeah i know
that's why i love the ones with windows
and they're only like two or three that
have windows that really make you feel
like you can really get out of there
yeah so i mean i was really proud of my
house
and then now i've neglected it for the
outside a lot so i haven't really
but i still like it i would i would
sleep in these rooms yeah that's usually
the process right i feel like i did the
whole outside of my island before i did
the inside of my house yeah i love this
and the little lost item
yeah i loved i i basically forgot to
give it and then i was like oh
i could use this this yeah i love this
wallpaper when i got it i was just like
oh
oh yeah it's perfect it's so beautiful
i would i would love that wallpaper on
my actual wall
and you know you'll notice that all the
art is actually real
i don't give the real art to blathers
so oh god i drifted left again i'm sorry
just go across
just go across i'll catch up with you
god is so irritating
i'll be the other half of this statue at
the door okay good oh good
i love that raccoon statue very nice
very nice
what's up ariel and brandon and
everybody in the chat thanks for joining
us sorry
i'm just you know how much i love this
game so i have to just take it all in
she's taking it in nice for being here
i love it i love this like the potions
the simpsons panel custom designs is
like my favorite thing i know that's why
i 100 slots
i'm just like let me have more so i want
to put more
i'm going to put more like plants on the
wall here and i get another one of those
but i'm really happy with this seance
room i think it's pretty cool
yeah i love it especially with the floor
being all misty and nice
and yeah we don't have to go okay
upstairs and downstairs there's
kallipi's rooms because she won't move
out
this is what happens when you reproduce
so we could go upstairs
first she won't i was like can we just
take it and put it in your room
because i would love to have a library
upstairs or a game room no
no it doesn't want it so and a lot of my
mods
and every room i have a mom named tario
and she is like the pink princess
she's like the master of pink
her island she has the most beautiful
cherry blossom spa in her basement and
i'm just like it's so gorgeous
but she gave me a lot of that pink stuff
nice and i just went downstairs oh god
we just
we've become one yeah exactly
and then i'm collecting posters for this
room oh yay
oh i might have some extras i can give
you that oh yeah please do
send me some yeah so this is a nice room
again kaleidovi picked out all of it
i made all the furniture for her but she
really likes those bears we have
probably 25 bears i love them
though they're so cute yeah so that's my
house it would be nice to have
a gym or like i said an arcade a library
but you know
i'm not going to move her out if she
doesn't want to move out she's only
three years old
yeah i just have to make another house i
was thinking about it i don't think i
have the real estate though you'll see i
pretty much have everything covered now
so i'm like sweating if they add more
buildings to the game
i know i don't know what'll happen i'll
have to kick other people out so this is
my patio
nice and i really like this custom
pattern on the ground
um and so a lot of this white stuff is
inspired by instagram i have a couple of
people i follow on the gram
and i'm i will confess that a couple of
areas i just kind of like
took for inspiration from them i mean
sometimes you see something you're just
like i need that
i know that yeah the next area we look
at will be that
um this is a fruit stand because i love
smoothies there's an acai bowl right
here
i was like but yeah it makes much more
sense i can see
yeah yeah you know i would be really
enriching my co-workers when we were
still in the office
every day they were eating a cycle i
know they're so good though and they're
so good for you you know and i just love
the idea i didn't really want
development near my house but the beach
was so big and i was like what would i
want out right outside my house
a smoothie shop
in this area like i just kind of like
tried to
decorate in a way that you know i added
a couple plants here
so i you know i like to try to make the
most i've never seen this sky
oh oh this is over here oh is he
shouting at you oh my god he's so creepy
i found him on an island i was like i
have to have it i love
his house is right here come over here
and look this is my b
this is my pool area man your custom
like floorings
are amazing oh thank you this is
lindbergh's house i wish he was in he's
the creepy little mouse that has a five
o'clock shadow and where
he wears a yeah so this his my okay so
every one of my villagers you'll see has
a theme
uh based on you know kind of their
personality and so lindbergh
is like a sort of like a mad scientist
meets big lebowski
so that's why i put him over here with
all these papers on the floor
and then this is klaus's area i need to
get a couple more statues
how fancy if you go into his house it's
a bath house he's a creeper
like he's a no he's a guy who'll like
bring you in for wine and like get you
in the hot tub and just like a little
bit of a creeper his hair is so badly
like blonde
it's so trumpy and it's just creepy so
that's why i was going with him
nailed it and he hits on you too he's a
total creeper that's why i picked him up
okay so this area is 100 instagram um
what's this show
so i really love it i went with this
kind of soft white tones everywhere
um it just makes me happy and i loved
using sort of some of the fossils as
decoration too
some of them are super nice yeah so each
section
i just really wanted to sort of i love
the idea yeah i love that
yeah and this little lookout area
and then coming through here
um and then we have this is a hundred
percent from
uh an instagram i follow this little
seafood area
but i just loved it so much i was like
okay this is i have to have this on my
island
i know now that we have diving i wanna
red lobster and put the lobster tanks
around like
that would be so great so that might be
a future
idea yeah but i love this area it makes
me
just makes me happy so like just imagine
in real life if you went to somewhere
like this or right
she would be like i would love it yeah i
would love it
okay so then then we'll go okay yeah so
we'll come around here and then we'll go
upstairs
and then we'll go gosh this is gonna
take a while oh no we're okay okay so
we'll just keep going
um like sometimes you don't realize how
much stuff you've packed onto your
island until you give someone a tour i
know oh he's such a creeper look at him
don't go with him in line
i know we're over here i'm staying next
to my stay next to me
[Music]
let's go upstairs first and then we'll
go through the coffee area
afterwards so upstairs i just kind of
was working on this area a lot
so this is kind of like an open mic sort
of outdoor
uh i couldn't really know what else to
do with that area we have a little movie
theater here
oh i like the way you use the bell
tickets
thank you yeah yeah i just created
thank you and then over here
um i just did this area for this tour so
i'm pretty happy with it
exclusive reveal world premiere we're
from here so this is my food court
and i love it so much so we have sushi
we have ice cream i need to get the
popsicles from the winter area to put
right there and that'll really
finish off that stall and then we've got
um a cake stand and a pizza area
oh my goodness i love it i love this
food court it's actually
i mean see i'm really into food so the
food areas i was like how can i make
them better i
love pizza i actually have this custom
design on my island you do
yeah and the pizza hat looks good yeah
it's so great because like you know in
new york when they have all the pizzas
like out on the desktop
exactly i love that and this is what i
chose to do in front you can't really
see the whole thing
because but i i just did a couple of um
i did a couple of those uh dinosaur
bones and i took this
uh i think it was on instagram maybe i
love the idea of breaking this up
with the the rope not just doing all
hedges i really like that idea
it looks more exhibit like it does yeah
and then up here we have a reading area
which i really love
it's so pretty yeah again instagram so
anything you see that's white
is probably instagram there are a couple
of people i follow i wish i remember
their names
um you know what i want to give them a
shout out but by the end of the stream
yeah as i'm traveling i'll look it up
and then this so this is
uh chops he's kind of a self-righteous
weird looking pig
and i couldn't really and then i was
inspired because he is
dressed in sort of a 19th century uh
outfit and he has like this very
like old-fashioned interior so i decided
he was an atelier
for um ancient costumes and stuff and
cosplay
nice so this is his yard and cosplay he
was the originator guys
he's the og yeah he's a pig and he's
super
snobby and i just love the idea of him
doing uh you know
only uh sort of reenactment outfits
and then we have um my little zen garden
which is one of the first things i built
because you know they have so many
beautiful things
and i really just love the idea of
having a peaceful area you could just
sit in so that's
and it made it made use of some area
that was sort of thin
and i couldn't really build on and it
allowed me to get up there
oh yeah we'll get there so there we go
that's that area
that's my upstairs and then
we can go downstairs to see other i
really am proud of every single square
inch
except for some like transition areas
yeah i need to do something with this
tree but it's fine
nature oh yeah let's do the coffee house
and then we'll
this is my oh i love it i'm going to say
it's my favorite even though i say that
50 000 times this is my friend's cafe it
just feels like
yay kind of cafe i go to there's marina
ah she's so cute hello
hello marina i moved her to the beach
and she's so much happier you guys she
used to be in the house up here
so we have two houses over here i love
this house because i love what i did
with the um
the fences because this is an art studio
so i just used one of these fenced
yeah this is chevro's house chev
so you know i just wanted her to be an
artist and i love the way that
around you know she has a kiln
oh i like how you repurpose your beach
tile
for this uh-huh yeah well i had to do
something because i'm running out of
space you know what i'm saying and then
this is ketchup who i used an amiibo for
and she has the farm
oh god i'm so sorry it's so cute yeah
the farm
and i love this oh yeah the
dream beetle or whatever that thing is
called so i
i use the custom tile with the um with
the pumpkin but then i planted all this
other stuff to make it look more 3d
those are coconuts and
rubs i love it i love
like seeing all the farm ideas because i
know
like similar but they're all unique when
like which items you choose like i've
seen some with the
beach ball watermelons yes i've seen i
tried that and just looked fake to me
even though this whole game is big
this is my tardis oh snap i really had
to
i love and then this is calliope now of
course this was half the size but she
wanted a bigger playground
so and this is this is a real i think
this is the real statue and i just think
it's funny that i have a priceless
statue on the playground
makes me laugh yeah even though the one
with the antennas will float
when you like touch it oh really yeah oh
pro tip all right so then
we'll go oh you know what come down this
way because i want to do the front of
the beach so oh this this area this is
my
greenhouse um shop it's really cute
those window panes yeah they look nice
right
yeah and this is uh ricky he's a cranky
squirrel and i just decided he was trash
squirrel
so ricky's just because and i love the
fact he's in town so the grossest
house is in town oh my goodness
so funny and his pet bug
yeah his pet bug whatever's in there and
so this is my beach area i love love
love i took this off of instagram this
little shower
it makes me so happy
and then we've got water hold on oh yeah
don't do that i hate it when i come in
and i left a
tap on even virtually um and here's my
little beach at front beach area
and then um then we have ricky's
backyard which is so gross
i need to get a couple more of these
gross you know outdoor shares
and this is marina so i moved her to the
beach and i gave her the mermaid
furniture
oh that's perfect i'm still trying to
get this one
uh one of my one of my uh community
members had 40 pearls i was just like
what i don't know what she had a secret
to getting them
oh snap um i think it's because they
don't cast a shadow so she just
somehow she was able to identify it oh
interesting
okay so this is my campsite another one
of my favorite areas
and i love i just really went crazy with
the campsite area just how big it was
so i love using weeds to decorate yeah
it feels
very camp like for sure
yeah i love even the beach area and then
there's a little fishing area up there
like there's a seating area here and
then down here
there's a little cot which i would love
to sleep on and then down here we've got
the
the beach with a little bit of
recreation
and then over here we've got a little um
little library which i love the little
seating area with a library
five star watch show yeah
and then there's a little yes all right
not even gonna lie
here's a ten yours a ten star no i don't
know yours is a tim star
most people put a campsite in a really
small area i'm like let's make it a real
campsite
i know i'm like rethinking my whole
campsite now oh that's nice
and then we've got a little blanket area
because i didn't know what else to do
with that area
um this is my favorite this is rudy
who's my fav is he a fitness instructor
he's a jock
he's a jock cat so he he's always taught
calling me mush and i love him so yeah
he does spin class every morning
goodness
whatever and then he has a little gym
over here
i love you know you always give the
jocks all the goods
there's so much stuff there's so much
good stuff in here right and it worked
out perfectly like
the real estate i just love the spin
class idea it just makes me laugh a lot
also chat don't forget that play for all
our donation drive is still open until
the end of august
and we now have merch we have our store
open at store.gamespot.com and all the
proceeds from that are
being donated also so don't forget thank
you chastity and chat for reminding me
i lost silence i want to give a shout
out to the games that i i
have i'm doing a voice in um it's coming
out august 27th on steam and it's called
the dungeons of nachelbeck
and it's this it's just this hilarious
comedy fantasy game that's
um like a tactical rpg so it's
turn-based
and i play the wizard in the chair
in there and she's so snarky the
dialogue is kind of like buffy
everybody's so snarky each other it
makes me laugh so hard it's originally a
french game
but i got to play the wizard in
um uh the english version and it's
coming out
august 22nd 27th so if you guys like
really funny games where
you the graphics are so cute um
definitely check it out
nice that explains the hat yeah okay
we're going to go upstairs
first and i know i love being a wizard
she had i mean i
have to tell you it took like a week
over a week to record on the dialogue
this is my favorite
villager tia i mean and look what i did
yes
it totally matches tia doesn't it
and there's cherry we're going to go to
her house in a second where you saw the
cherry trees this is my
upstairs area and you know it's hard to
it's nice i need to put a bench here i
need to put a bench right there
yay the star stuff is so awesome i know
i love everything celeste i really do
um and then our last gosh this is it
so cherry is one of my og's and i kind
of want to kick her off because her
house is so basic
but was she one of the first ones then
yeah so her house is a little bit janky
but i moved her up here and i planted
cherry trees all around and i really
like it now you'll notice
do you notice this persia do you notice
there's a little sign here
oh yeah i see it yeah it's my secret
passage
watch come over here last but not least
oh my goodness the mystery do you have a
ladder
get it out yes oh good i should have
told you to get a ladder
i keep all my thrills on me just in case
yeah you definitely need a ladder to get
here sorry for my tokyo drift i can't
get my ladder out
properly it really is it's gotten to the
point where it's just not even usable
you got to come down into the exclusive
club oh my gosh
look mom i made it we got to go around
the concierge desk and we got a
lab we got a dance floor
we also have a casino
yeah yeah yeah baby
[Applause]
yeah and it's a casino too so i've got a
bunch of these
art boards and wow this is definitely
casino vibes right here
yeah i'm wearing it hit big no whammies
let's come oh my
god yeah so and there's like a little
pool
like a billiards area magic
and everything i love it yeah is that my
that's my hidden area i'm pretty proud
of it
it's my probably my favorite it's
actually super hidden because even when
we were at the seafood right you didn't
see it did you do that
yeah i know i had a tree there and i was
almost too distracted because you looked
at the tree and i was like
awesome so that's my island
well 10 out of 10. i loved it
what's your favorite part persia i would
have to say my favorite part is also the
food court
because i love food also yeah
but seeing everybody like incorporate
food and stuff into their islands
because like i have a couple restaurants
on my island too
oh i can't wait to see are we going
there no yeah
let's do it all right
all right guys we're heading to my
island now what'd you guys think of
felicia's
yeah what did you think oh my gosh i
loved it
she was under selling the island the
entire time she was like
i don't know i don't know some of my
friends and mods have islands that are
insane
so like i one of them has a castle
one of them has some really cool ones
like that too which are so oh there we
go
all right let me fly home i saw one
where they turned their whole island
into like a cruise ship
it was it was really cool oh really
everyone yeah
that's cool i saw a tour of a harry
potter island which was like
incredible love
good themes i've had a couple friends do
um like disney world themes and stuff
super cool i just like let me give a
shout out to these instagram
because um i love them so much there's
two of them that i'm like oh
i just every day i'm like oh okay and
they like they really
they really i think they're professional
designers or something you know what i'm
saying it's like oh wow
okay they are uh
love i think she's italian
l a v i e i n
o c h i l a v i
e i n o c h i
um i also love miss m-i-s-s
underscore a-c-n-h
and i also love crossing inspiration
those are the three that i really love
all right i am flying in on my seaplane
oh wow it already looked it already
looked amazing
how many hours a day do you spend on
this game persia
well when like the past few weeks i've
been like a little bit busy but
like before that and since it came out i
was playing like every day
for like hours and hours yeah i think
i'm almost at like
800 hours like because i also have a
second switch
and another island that i'm working on
so okay oh you want to open your islands
yeah i'm gonna best friend you though so
that
you can get the code oh okay
um there we go wait so i can make a more
exclusive code
oh okay great or can i just fly over
um i'm gonna uh
can i just fly over you open it i'm just
worried other people might join in
oh okay because you're so you need to
type me
a code yeah
or i mean if i make it if you only open
your best friends
wait what
what's up well can you type it in the
discord
oh no hey can you type it in the
description if you can see it
oh gotcha okay okay okay so then maybe
just open your island to best friends
yeah and then hopefully people won't pop
over
sounds good
all right give it a shot it is so so do
you have different themes for your
island
um i basically tried to make all my
villagers houses like super luxurious
so most of my space went into like their
land
um and then i have like other areas just
for like things that i like
like i love pizza i got pizza shop oh i
like
coffees i also have a cafe and
i one of my villagers have free health
care so i built them a hospital
oh i've wanted to you know i got that
thing where you measure people i was
like god
a clinic would be really cool and i
didn't have i don't have enough real
estate for it but i can't oh i want to
see it is it on this island or the other
island
what's on this one yeah is that you okay
um
what is that you flying in poopy
do you know a lot of other people well i
have a lot of best friends
so it's like
they might join in which is not a bad
thing we just you know
i don't know how long it speaks to like
fly into an island so i don't want to
like
yeah waste everyone's time with dodo
screen even though
i do like the dodo music
i'm pretty excited yeah so
um let's see oh wow oh you have leaf
today
i need some bushes buy it up
i hope you're so good with your flowers
this is what i'm going to be envious of
because i'm really too lazy to put any
effort into that
i mean i look at those you know you have
like a strip of two by two and you're
just like what do i do with this if i
put some effort
into it maybe i could find something
good but i don't care
all right welcome let me get my
wand doctor
right up front oh how did you get the
mushrooms
um it was it's a fall diy
because my island is called vandal city
because i love teemo from league of
legends
and everywhere so i was like i need
mushrooms on my island
that is real they're so cute i am gonna
have to rip out a whole area
to do okay i'm gonna follow you
oh it's so cute we have the same color
palette
i love it um really nice
and then leaf is here if you want my
flag is teemo
because i had to adorable
did you make that uh i did actually i
used that
image converter website so
yeah we'll start down here by renee's
house
i love that i need to buy that thing
she's super cute and she's like free
spirited so i gave her a lot of like
puzzles and
oh cute i love your patterns
look at this cute little shower
oh that's really nice
hi renee uh
girl comb your bangs you know she's
reliving those emo days
i'm just messing with you she's a
stalker
she's like oh i know you okay just
shove it okay next and then
here's my cafe oh
thank you i didn't know you could put a
sign on those low screens
that is so brill
oh my gosh look at your little outfit
this is so cute
i have my employee here one latte
stat how do you do that oh my god it's
so cute
ah this is to die for i love it
i also like the idea of an open mic so i
had to put like an
open mic thing i love how do you have
room for all your d
like i love the pattern to make the
little that i love
if i could do anything i would just have
more floor patterns that is so cute
yeah i actually reused just a lot of the
same pattern
well you have to it's just it's torture
i will pay you 100
for 10 more slots okay just give it to
me
thanks aaron um
i love this sign every custom pattern i
love
and then if we keep going up this way
this is my house which is so cute
i love pants she's wearing her yellow
bow today which makes me so happy
did you give it to her okay please wear
this
it'll be so cute on you okay i'm
following you sorry this is very nice
the way you did this
i love museums and i was like it needs
to feel museum-y
yeah i love the way you use the fossils
this is my house but i've been kind of
neglecting it so we can go through it
really quickly my god
look at all the how do you have so many
five-star
i can't i don't they won't give me more
for some reason
i don't know we usually grow on your
cliff sides only so make sure you leave
a couple of slots open on your cliff
sides for
them whoa this is amazing
okay yeah it took me forever to make
this thing and it cost 50 customization
kits to color and i was like you know
what you're getting your own room that's
it uh yeah this is incredible
proscenium this is incredible i love it
yeah i keep looking at it in my diys i'm
like you should make that i'm like i'm
never gonna
no cause gold is too hard
yeah and and like also gulliver oh this
is so cute
this is like the office slash
like little room i love the uh tea table
is that a custom
uh pattern or is that just one of them
it's a it's a custom
diy it's really cute
i love the fish what fish is that uh the
betta
or yeah i think i caught one of those
i'm so lazy though i really don't
that is a nice room thank you
and my kitchen
this is when i was telling you this
wallpaper doesn't have windows but i
just i love this wallpaper and shout
outs to cali for giving you this
wallpaper you're the best
yeah oh wow oh this wallpaper is so
where is this wallpaper what i've never
seen this before
i don't think it's a sahara wallpaper
but i haven't
gotten it from sahara at all and my
friend gave him never seen this
wallpaper it is
super cute oh i love what you did here
see my kitchen needs an upgrade and i
love the space you did here
is that a rug under here or what um the
dark bamboo mat i think a diy also
okay you've really inspired me here
because i love the dark colors you used
yeah i even had to customize like the
the cake
i was like i need the chocolate cake
yeah it looks great
this is like a museum like that opening
it's just like woof
the only cool thing about this bathroom
is this gold toilet
[Laughter]
oh it's so good yeah i wish i had room
for a separate bath you know i had to
come by but you know have you ever been
in a hotel room where you had the
bathroom
you had the bathtub next to the bed um
i think once i did i thought it was so
elegant so
even though practically you would not
want a bathtub in your bed
with my luck the whole room would be
soaked can't risk it
yeah this is my hair
but i just like hanging stuff on the
wall but yeah i have a bunch of uh extra
posters and stuff that i'm gonna
it's so pretty the mermaid stuff is just
so lovely
i need to get some too you can't
customize it yeah it would be nice if
you could customize it because the pink
is a little like
very specific i need to put give marina
some i have some extra pieces i need to
give her like the armor and stuff so she
can decorate her inside too
yeah um this bottom room is just my
turnip room
so i already sold them all so there's
nothing in here oh no
my turn oh my god
what what's going on so my fire alarm is
going off and my bill you need to leave
you know a bunch of kids always pull our
fire alarm in our building
which is really annoying all right but
if you smell fire could you leave please
yes no worries
[Music]
like how can i still talk without
killing everyone's ears
i mean i'm okay with that but it's okay
it's adding to the tour
it is exactly this is an emergency tour
we need
everything oh flute i need this
space i need this food where do you have
food
yeah that's the um cherry blossom picnic
tape
oh that's why i have the cherry blossom
i think i started playing right after
the evening
i don't have any of that stuff
this is cute whose house is this so this
is henry
he's my froggy boy and by the way his
house
he is did you give it to i'm gonna go
inside okay
yeah no he naturally showed up on my
island like this
really in the ironwood furniture and i
was like i want
oh wow wow this guy has wow
did you and he you gave him all this or
did he already had it
no he already came equipped with all of
this stuff henry
comes from frog money yeah that's why i
made his slot super fancy wow
okay move it he's cute though i didn't
think i'd like a frog but i really think
he's cute
i love him so much and sometimes him and
pancetti hang out together
it's cute a french person we eat both of
you
so yeah i made this area surrounded by
lots of water
yeah no i love that did you terraform a
lot here yeah
i love the little little um island i
oh you can jump on them too cute
this is dopey i love him so much he's
like one of my favorites
this is a lovely area
this is gorgeous i love the way you
segmented the area
isn't it amazing how the more stuff you
put in the bigger it looks i think
that's a
interior design kind of situation
oh nice this is great
i love it oh wow i love the diagonal it
makes me feel so long
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i just committed a lot of real estate to
my campsite i just loved
i really wanted that natural vibe and
that's why i love just letting the weeds
go
this is really cute though and it's like
a lat pool you could get in
how rude teddy's really cute
does he come with that did he come with
that crusader thing is he like a
crusader
oh you gave it to him he looks pretty
cute i got him from another villager and
then he ran up to me and he was like i
need it
really i hate it when that you know
marina i i started being really good
friends with her and she just sends me
every day and i'm like girl back off
we're not that good
um oh beautiful
[Music]
little area yeah that's kind of nice oh
so great
pancetti you know she she's fancy
so i gave her easy access to the
infinity pool
um
wait a minute can you customize the
peach to be yellow this just blew my
mind
[Music]
actually you blew my mind i think it's
so much cuter in yellow
what and then over here
is my little lobby into my pizza shop
oh my god i love the sign
pizza house oh look at your outfit come
on
and you know i have my workers over here
my gnome buddies
[Music]
i love it so much and it looks so real
like i love the way you've mixed all the
different furniture together but it
blends together
yeah and then like log round tables
you can like customize something in the
middle and it looks like a menu
i had no idea that is so cute
i'm gonna have to use these low screens
because i literally had no idea i only
have those other signs
[Music]
you can customize too yeah yeah i just
saw that but
you know i'm so i'm out of custom space
i really
i have to like uh you know sophie's
choice them and i know that's not a
really good analogy for a video game
that's about
children when it's about a woman between
which child should
would die but um
[Music]
well i just want to eat all the foods
which is
i love that orange rose the orange rose
and the orange hyacinths are my two
favorites
i just love that soft orange color it's
so nice
[Music]
i put this here because he's in my
flyover
oh it looks great
felicia i missed you in eureka thank you
[Music]
and this is teddy's house so yeah
oh it looks good i love it i didn't oh
you can do a pink protein powder that's
cool
i love i love like the white bars like
you're not crunk
you're yeah you're shy they're
[Music]
he really got he got front row access
there like really take care of the guy
who takes care of your abs
and then this is fona's house she's
probably my favorite villager
fauna oh oh fawn is so pretty is she in
i want to see her
[Music]
she's so precious yeah she's really cute
i
almost amiibos her or diana because i
really want to hear
oh we've never met right i'm fauna oh my
gosh she's so cute is she normal
um i just said hi to her
she's so cute i kind of i want to go
really badly but i don't know who to
kick off i love all of them so much i'm
kind of like really happy i amiibo
out sherry who was the scourge of a
nation and then i amiiboed out
uh zucker even though people like him i
was like i don't need two octopuses
okay fire alarm is off thanks to heavens
but yeah so i tried to fit her her red
theme and relax
she's just very calm and precious and i
love her i love
the deers i i now i'm in love with the
frogs because now i see a frog in person
honestly though i have not seen another
frog that i like it's only henry
okay i got you um so this is my little
heart pond it was the first thing i care
about
i got my that's really cute
yeah it's so cute and i love the i love
the hyacinth is 100 my favorite flower
um so this field here feel free to take
any
flowers you see right here this is my
overgrowth field oh my gosh
look at this i can't get rid of because
i feel really bad throwing them away
so wow oh oh gosh you have an anteater
annabelle she's kind of cute oh it's a
pangolin i
love annabelle she's cute she's
eaters are real ugos okay but the but
she's pretty cute
um so yeah that's my extra flower area
this is tasha's house and
her whole theme is like black and white
she's my black and white squirrel she's
super
cute she has a rainy city wallpaper in
her house
oh wow so she's an emo she's an emo
squirrel
gotcha i love it purple area the same
way
i love this this oh i love this little
oh this is nice look at that
whoosh and this uh square
box here is the safe that i turned
around oh how clever
yeah outside you can't really see that
angle anyways
i love it when people do things i like i
really like all the accents you have
here this is really lovely
sometimes i look at the customization
i'm like how do you use that and then
like you really made it happen
and i didn't really know what to do with
the center area between their house
because before it was just a bunch of
fruit trees but where stock market
and now oh yeah eat it anywhere so i
turned this into like a little
pagoda that's lovely no i love how
there's a lot of open space like your
your island is you put so much detail
work into it but
at the end of the day it feels open and
not too over developed this is
amazing this is annabelle's house she's
my little superstar so i was like you
know she needs to
have her privacy have her pool every day
why just sent me a blackboard wall oh
thank you abby why
someone said that one in my kitchen
actually is that the one in your kitchen
i love it
thank you i'm gonna actually oh this is
great
oh yes this is my i actually set it up
to where
each instrument can be stood at by
someone and like played
like everyone's gonna have a little jam
session it's really nice
i love that piano i love it yeah this
one is the stand-up piano and then you
can get
a custom diy for a street piano and it
costs like one
upright piano and like something else
but i think it's a paint it's a paint uh
kit
yeah i don't have the diy but i know one
day i'm gonna get that for collecting
oh this is cute claude he's my lazy
bunny he's super cute
you have a lot of laziness yeah you know
i try to
reflect my inner style
i kicked off all the lazies i'm like you
if you're gonna be on this thing
you gotta work i have a lot of normals
and i have a lot of snooties and i think
that's probably me inside too
this is my lover's peak this is my area
i offer to my friends when they want to
go on a date night
oh nice make sweet sweet love and animal
crossing
you know send those love emojis it's
really beautiful
this is perfect for valentine's day
and yeah just places to sit lots of pink
and stats just like your genitals
everything's pink just like you're just
no wonder i love it so much are you
excited also
teddy what are you doing over there whoa
teddy you've never
seen him whoa teddy come on
he's just really trying to get out he's
like let me out
um so my statue of liberty is down there
oh that's great
if you oops take the ladder down there
you can actually walk on this little
pier area
i made for it let me see oh that's
really nice can you do a custom pattern
on a rock i didn't know you could do
that yeah
[Music]
teddy moved teddy moved teddy moved
teddy moved teddy
teddy move get out of here okay where am
i going
um you can go down one more level okay
i just had to abuse your bear it's okay
he's strong you can't really see i can't
get down you can press
y or x and open your pocket oh that's
you want to see over the edge a little
oh i didn't know you could do that see
oh it's so cute okay
oh i just go down here
now that you can like jump into the
water from the rock areas i kind of
would
might open up this little fence yeah
we're gonna do that so
this is so cool i love what you did down
there
it's very majestic i was at the point
where i was really running out of space
and i'm like where am i gonna put this
statue
um then i guess we can go i have a
little
you know seaside area oh i want to see
it
wait where'd you go are you down
and this is where i was thinking about
replacing
this area with like another house and
turning it into red lobster
oh you have to
you have to do a red lobster it's too
funny
it's just perfect now with the lobsters
uh-huh you have to do it now
and now the last part of the island
is the hospital wait where'd you go oh
sorry i'm by the open mic okay hi
sorry i want to see the hospital i'm so
excited to see the hospital i saw one
person on reddit
who was a nurse and she made kind of
like an exam room
but that's the only thing i've ever seen
anybody do
all right well here we'll go in this
place since the entrance
is over here so cute hey how did you get
uh marshmallows
it's one of the leaf camp fire customers
oh
cute i did not see you know there's so
many different customizations it's like
every day you go to somebody else you're
like oh i didn't know you could
customize that
all right so i put the hospital like in
the inner city you know because
i feel like and then this is for you
oh thank you
oh oh oh and then
i am going to are we going to suit up
yes oh my god this is so funny
yeah where are my eyeglasses oh they're
there
oh this is fantastic amazing
amazing this is
amazing let's go
all right this is i like spent a lot of
time on this i
looked up literally on google of like
wow so there's multiple rooms and oh my
god
this is incredible it looks like a real
hospital
and so obviously this is the waiting
room and i am in love
this is the cutest thing i have seen in
animal crossing
i have if you have seen the diy recipe
for medicine
it's um it is a wasp-ness and
weeds so i kind of have like those items
out like making it seem like you know
we're getting
better it is
so cute and then of course you know
there's always the break room i watch a
lot of grey's anatomy
i know they have break rooms i've seen
oh yes this is cute you can take a
little nap if you're on a shift
this is amazing this um white board is
actually like a
i don't know i guess an evidence board
but i feel like i just pretend it's you
know these nurses are taking care of
these people oh yeah it's a shift it's
like to take care of shifts
oh that's so cute it really is cute you
did a great job
and then um
we'll go to this side i'm gonna leave it
a surprise for you and i can tell you
what it is
to the left okay yes what is
it it's a dissection room
stitches is open on my table oh my
goodness
so this is my o.r you know we got all of
you you
did an incredible job here
this is epic you can lay in that in the
cot and then i usually just pretend that
i'm like
you know all right time to start start
up the machine okay open me up
and then i'll be like go over here to
this
i'm having seizures i'm having seizures
i'm having
seizures oh no stat
step the doctor is too stressful oh god
oh no
i'm better thank you doctor
and wow
that was that is so incredible the way
you laid that out like i'm very in awe
get operated on this is top 10. i'm
telling you
then you'll uh you know get your
recovery
oh wow look at this my god is that a
simple panel
yes wow i am really
impressed like even when you twirl
around this 100 looks like a doctor room
like it's so incredible what you did wow
yeah this heart wallpaper when i first
saw it i was like i have no idea i'm
going to use this form but they also
have a red version and i was like oh
now i know what i'm using no no it's
amazing it's amazing
i'm so happy wait there's more yes there
is more
so doc if you look on your map um the
character i design in this house is
actually named doc
okay she is just like you know in my
mind she's the best doctor in the world
she's
good at everything so i wanted to
reflect in her office
total meredith gray kind of oh this is
great
meredith gray on the case it's a master
at like
using this katana she plays the piano
wow
trophies she's incredible this is really
beautiful i love how you use the
bookcase as a separator because it
really makes the room feel more spacious
and like wow and then of course you know
no good hospital is complete without an
extensive research facility
so downstairs we have our super high
tech lab
wow research wow get rid of fleas we're
researching wasps and why they
bite us and we're figuring out how to
reproduce it
like crossbreed a a pig and a frog
exactly trying to figure out what
happened to henry to made him into a
frog even though we can catch frogs
exactly what's going on on this island
it's like the goofy pluto situation we
don't even know what's going on this is
crazy good we're like reverse
engineering the wasps nests over here
we're fine we were gonna tr you're
trying to try to make a wasp villager
aren't you
hey that's classified information
this is incredible i have to say this is
the cutest thing
you have to i'm just i'm i'm in awe this
is so cute
thank you every detail like you just
twirl around you're just like this is a
real
this is real the surveillance is going
on
at vandal city you know yeah it's beyond
amazing it's true coffin cat there we go
well that's incredible
thank you for allowing me thanks for
to tour that i can't believe we just
spent an hour doing this
and this is you know we have the parking
lot and this is the pathway for the
ambulance to come
and then boom i'm going to give you back
your i need to give you back here
oh it is i could keep the nurses outfit
and let people know free healthcare on
vandal city yeah you know what
healthcare is great guys why not make it
free somehow with the money that we pay
the government
okay all right well thank you
for having me thank you for joining
don't forget to buy from leaf if you
needed something i will
and um just another shout out to my game
that i'm doing a voice in dungeons of
naholbeck
is going to be out august 22 7 on uh
steam and it's a really super fun
tactical rpg with lots of snarky humor
and fun fun characters to play with so
definitely i would play it if i weren't
in it so
check it out you guys coming soon and
also don't forget that our donation
drive for play for all is open until the
end of august
and we also open a merch store where you
can get play for all merch
and shirts and a skateboard it's all
super cool and all those proceeds are
also going towards play for all
we've literally raised thousands of
dollars thanks you guys
and yeah it's open to the end of august
so thank you all so much for joining us
thank you so much felicia for being i'm
so happy to show off all the hard work
that i
have put into this as an adult woman i
thought it was absolutely amazing
i already have some things i want to
redo after seeing your island so yeah
that's why i love this game so much just
like thank you when you think you're
done
there's still more stuff to do no it's
true it is really creative it's creative
and everybody's personality comes out
and that's the kind of game we want to
play right now
all right all right thanks so much see
you later bye
[Music]
don't
[Music]
[Music]